Hello, and welcome
welcome back,
everyone, to
Knowledge Connections
twenty twenty.
I'm Jozana Diotis, and,
I'm your host here
on the Innovators
track. And,
we keep we keep
pushing through
with more great talks.
We're here today with,
Juan Sequeira and Brian Jacob
from data dot org.
Who are here to
talk to us about
data catalogs,
knowledge graphs,
and how these two
are connected,
and how you can use knowledge
graphs to to power your data.
The floor is yours,
Juan and Brian.
Take it away. Great.
Thank you very much, George,
and we're excited to be here.
So, this talk when
when we wanted
to have a talk here,
Brian and I were
thinking about
something to be having
a a a different
bold point of view,
and and that's the goal
of this talk.
So, just a little
bit about us.
My name is Juan Cicada.
I'm I'm
the principal scientist
at data dot world.
I've been in this,
knowledge graph space,
which goes back
to the original
semantic web vision for almost
fifteen years. This is where I
started doing my
research, and I have,
I did my PhD at the University
of Texas at Austin.
We spun out our research into
a company called
CapCenta, which we did,
kind of pioneered
a lot of the semantic
graph virtualization
on relational
databases, developed Grapho,
our visual collaborative real
time knowledge graph
scheme editor.
And and we we sold
the company.
We're acquired by by
Brian's company,
data dot world,
and I've been part of kind of
bridging the world between
academic and industry,
being on many
standards committees,
and and now working
on the property
graph schema working group.
And, I'll pass it on to Brian
to introduce himself. Great.
Thanks, Juan.
I as Juan said,
I'm the the one of
the cofounders,
the CTO for data dot world.
I I think, you know,
maybe my story is
a little bit similar,
but inverted to one's.
I, you know, grad
school twenty
years ago in AI
machine learning,
but really have spent the last
twenty years, you know,
starting and working
for a number
of of large
companies kinda more
in mainstream
data management.
And the idea behind data dot
world was to really
bring the power
of semantic web and knowledge
graph technology
into that world.
And so, that's how
I got connected
up with Juan and ultimately,
acquired his company
so that, you know,
we can kinda work
on this together.
So And this is a side note I
always tell people.
Brian at HomeAway,
there that was a company that
acquired over thirty companies
in ten years. So if there's
somebody who knows about data
integration, it's
Brian Jacob.
He has integrated over thirty
different systems
in just ten years.
That's people
spend integrating
one two different systems in
just two years.
So to take that in account.
So this is this is the kind of
your typical example
that you see.
Right? You have your
sources. Right?
And you have your
data producers,
the personas, like
data engineers
and data stewards.
They have all this
data from all
these different sources.
And the goal is to be able to
integrate this data,
to be able to
provide it to your
consumers of data,
like your data
analysts and your
data scientists who wanna be
able to go answer
your questions.
Right? And there's
this big gap.
And the typical
marketing or or
architecture slides,
it's that you put a knowledge
graph here in the middle.
But in reality,
what you start
seeing in here,
there's very specific
boxes. Right?
There's things like we need to
do data governance.
We need to have
a a business glossary,
a data glossary.
We need to have
data virtualization
and federation technology.
We need to do data quality.
We need to do data security,
data preparation,
data lineage,
data dot dot dot data,
more data data.
Tomorrow, there's
gonna be more
data things that
we need to go do.
And all these
different aspects
are needed to be able to go
integrate data.
So just simply kinda
slapping on that,
oh, a knowledge graph is gonna
solve us here. The devil's in
the details, and there's a lot
of details in here.
And this is the big
question is
how do you figure
out what you need?
Our position is that you wanna
start on two
important pillars.
The first is
a pillar on metadata
management, and
the next is a pillar
on data management.
So you want to
be able to start
build your strong
foundation on
top of metadata management and
data management,
And that is our definition of
what a data catalog
should be.
Now a data catalog wants need
you need to be able to go do
things with quality
and security
and preparation and so forth.
But depending on
your use case,
data quality may
be more important
than data lineage.
Data preparation might be more
important than data security.
So that's why you
don't need to
really think about
boiling the ocean
and bringing all these
things together.
You wanna start on these very
important pillars
and then bring
in the other tools
that you need.
And how do you bring in these
other tools? The
knowledge graph
is what really
helps put to put
this stuff in together.
Because what we're gonna go
discuss here is that because
everything is driven
by connections,
and and and we
can start putting
connecting all these different
systems together to ultimately
be able to create your
knowledge graph.
So I've introduced
two terms here,
data catalog and
the knowledge graph.
A data catalog is
a metadata and
data management
tool that helps
users inventory
and organize and
access the data within
their systems.
And the knowledge graph,
I know there are just so many
different definitions
and stuff,
and and and this is
what I call Juan's,
nonscientific, non pedantic
definition of
a knowledge graph.
You wanna do data integration
where you're
integrating internal
and also external
data sources.
And second is that
you want your
real world concepts and
relationships to
be first class
citizens, And
those concepts end
up being nodes in a graph,
and the relations that end up
being edges in the graph.
And that's a simple definition
of what a knowledge graph is.
So with that,
let me go pass it
on to Brian because I want him
to go tell us why your data
catalog should be
powered by a knowledge
graph. So I'm gonna start by
talking about the relationship
in this direction.
The data catalog is powered by
your knowledge graph.
So a graph data model
is, by definition,
flexible and agile.
It's about entities
and relationships,
and it can be open open world
in the sense that
you can bring
in new entities and
relationships.
So that as you
move across your
organization, acquire
new data sources,
uncover new data sources,
you can bring those
into the model
in a flexible way.
Data quality,
security, lineage,
all of these kind of use cases
of of a metadata management
system are represented
in the knowledge
graph as relationships between
the between entities.
And it's you know,
as with any application,
it's not that you can't build
this application on
top of tabular,
you know, relational
SQL databases.
It's that when you think about
the kind of expansiveness and
the openness of
this problem by
modeling it at
where the entities
and the relationships
are first
class citizens,
you end up putting the data,
the actual meaning
of what you're
representing first,
and you build
a more flexible,
usable, and and and powerful
implementation to
power discovery,
search, recommendations across
those data assets.
And and one thing
to add here,
if you look at
other companies,
like the Airbnbs
of the world,
right, that they
built their own
data catalogs,
guess what they built
the catalog on?
They built it on
graphs. Sure.
So thinking about
the use cases
that we talked about for for
data catalog, for metadata
management system.
For when when you think about
the first thing
you wanna think
about is cataloging
your data assets.
What data assets do exist and
how are they related
to one another?
This is this could
be represented by,
you know, by go back
one one slide one.
This represented
by, you know,
thinking about those database
tables and databases as nodes
in the graph and
the relationship
of containment as
as a relationship
between them.
Going forward to discovery,
you wanna understand what data
assets are related
to a topic,
what physical assets like this
table are related to,
what logical concepts
like the concept
of order from my
business glossary
or from my taxonomy
of my organization.
You wanna think
about governance.
You wanna understand
what agents
and policies are related to
those data assets.
You know, again,
here is a simple example.
Reuben is a person
who is the steward
of this database.
Notice how each of
these statements
are a real world use case of
something I'd like
to understand,
but they are but but
but, ultimately,
they are represented
by modeling
the entities and
the relationships
as first class
citizen just like
in any graph based solution.
Provenance. How
are data assets
related to one another and and
over time and and and in a in
a derivation, in
a in a, you know,
in a state change
representation manner.
And collaboration.
What people are related to all
the data and
analytical artifacts?
If I want to understand all of
the data
the the the data assets
in my system,
it's one thing to
have kind of all
the relate all
the all the data
represented in
the catalog, but
you also wanna
understand who are the other
people who have
additional information,
who have actually
where is the prior
art and how who
else can I contact
who has actually touched this
data or has has a relationship
These things, these are all
concepts in the real world?
Your databases, your reports,
your your your
policies and people,
they're all real
world concepts.
They contain information about
other real world concepts and
relationships, but
they themselves
are concepts that
have relationships
to one another and
the information
they represent.
Regardless of how you actually
implement it,
your data catalog
is a knowledge graph.
It's a graph of of of of of
knowledge about these assets,
and it should be the starting
point for your enterprise
knowledge graph that kind of
speaks in the domain language
of your business.
So stepping through those use
cases again. You know, first,
I represent that this orders
table is part of
this particular
database. I
understand that that
orders table is
related logically
to the concept of orders.
I understand that
Ruben is the steward
of the sales database and that
there's a net sales
table derived
from that orders
table and a report
derived from that,
which was actually
produced by by Sally.
I all of these individual
statements are things that are
collected together
by introspecting
and understanding the metadata
about about these
data assets.
And these give
you when you ping
them bring them all together,
a graph over which
you can reason
and analyze your
data infrastructure
to understand where
where the where
where the actual data and know
and information
about your real
world entities lives.
So when you build this graph,
ultimately, you need a model
that helps you make
sense of this.
Your nodes are gonna represent
concepts like data
assets, databases,
tables, and columns,
the agents,
topics, etcetera.
The edges are gonna represent
things like containment,
things like like
logical relation,
things like derivation for
provenance and lineage.
And so what you
end up what you
end up with is
an ontology that
describes these that this this
interconnected network of of
data assets, of
your of of the of
the metadata about
your data assets.
What we what we have built
internally is not told you we
call Dweck, but, ultimately,
it is the majority of that of
that is vocabulary from these
open standards.
It uses things like DCAP for
the basic catalog structure,
Dublin Core for basic,
metadata about
digital assets,
Provo for lineage,
SCOS for concepts,
etcetera. The this is the this
is the ontology that you start
with to make sense of the data
assets themselves,
and it builds into the next
section that Juan
is gonna talk
about where you actually then
use that as the foundation to
build your
enterprise knowledge
graph that's in
the language of
your of your business.
And I'll just kind
of close with,
you know, thinking about one
specific use case and how this
kinda really makes it makes it
makes it real,
makes it visceral.
You know, a a common use case
for a data catalog
is to understand
lineage for things
like impact analysis.
And when you when
you do that,
what you're really
doing is saying,
I want to go into
the graph that
represents all
the ways that all
of my data assets
are interrelated,
and I wanna pull
out a subgraph
that looks at the looks at all
of these things
by along the the
derived from dimension.
I wanna basically pull out all
of the the ways
that things are
derived from in a prominent
sense so that I
look all the way
off to the right
here and say,
I have these several
Tableau reports,
and I would like to understand
where the data
that powers these
reports come from.
That is a query against that
graph that says,
give me
transitively everything
from which these things
are are derived.
This is just one
quick example that,
you know, I think
is is is a common
visual implementation in a in
a cataloging and and lineage
solution to show
you kind of how
you what you're
doing is really
querying across this graph
database and pulling
out an interesting
subgraph to address
a particular query.
With that, I'll hand
it back to Juan.
Great. So we the point here is
that your data
catalog is about
managing and
understanding your
metadata. And if
you're gonna do that,
it ends up being a graph.
So it ends up
being a knowledge
graph itself. But
I know everybody
here is really excited about
knowledge graphs,
and we're trying to
learn about that.
And our position is that your
knowledge graph
should be powered
by a data catalog.
So let's think about it.
When within organizations,
you don't know what
data you have.
This is the common problem
everybody has. Right?
We We don't know what data we
need to go search for data,
so let's go catalog it.
Let's go literally crawl and
bring in all that
metadata together.
But when you do that,
you wanna be able to start
connecting it together to
understand how things
are connected,
everything that Brian
just mentioned.
Once you start
cataloging that data,
you wanna go find the data,
the next thing is, like,
I wanna go access that data.
I found the data
that I needed.
Right? Regard I
talked to somebody.
I figured out how
things were connected.
I now wanna go
access that data.
Let it be give me access to
the raw data
because it's being
sent to me, or I wanna be able
to go query that data.
And at this point is when you
start realizing
that I I I I can
go query it using
data virtualization
technology, data
federation technology.
I wanna take a table in one
database and
the table in another
database and go join
them together.
Right? We wanna be
able to provide
users with that quick and easy
access to the data.
But this continues to be what
we call
the application centric
view of the data. Right?
When when we talk about real
world enterprise
databases that
you're cataloging,
you're cataloging
databases that
have hundreds, if
not thousands,
of tables and thousands,
if not ten thousand columns.
And at this point,
you want I mean,
our position is that you want
people to realize that their
data is a mess,
and you want them to kind of
crash into the wall
and realize,
wait. My data I don't
cataloging also the usage
of the people,
and you start
realizing what are
the different the most
important data,
assets that people
are querying.
You can start cataloging also
the queries that
people are doing,
and you realize, wow.
People are querying for orders
in all these three,
four different ways.
And when you start
talking to people,
you realize, wow.
You use the word order,
and it means three different
things to different people.
So you start realizing these
things once you
start cataloging
the data. And then when you
start cataloging the data and
accessing the data as it is,
people realize,
I don't understand my data.
And at that point is
when they realize,
I need to add my knowledge on
top of that data.
I don't want to go write these
really complicated application
centric view
queries to get what
is in order. I would like to
just have a concept
called order
and just access
the data through
that concept and get it.
But if we I think a tendency
that we see a lot is people
wanna jump into this knowledge
aspect first.
We call this to crawl,
walk, and run.
You wanna be able
to first crawl,
catalog your data, walk,
go access the data,
understand how that
data is today,
and realize that
there there are
a lot of pains, and
I understand it.
And when you start
cataloging the usage,
you start realizing which are
the aspects most
important to people.
And at that stage,
you start you can go go into
the running phase,
which is let's go create add
the knowledge to
it and go create
that knowledge graph.
And by doing this
crawl, walk,
and run,
it helps us focus
on what people
are actually using
and needing,
and that avoids
boiling the ocean.
Because this is something that
we have seen over
and over again,
that people want
to jump in and
create their knowledge graph,
and they start
building this big
knowledge graph
with having a clear
view of success.
So the crawl and walk is what
we call the the data catalog,
and the knowledge graph aspect
is when you're
starting to go run,
create that knowledge graph,
and then actually using that
knowledge graph.
That's why we say
the knowledge
graph should be
powered by your
data catalog in order
to be successful.
So to get a little bit more of
an example, when
you're starting
to go catalog,
this is an example
of a real world
enterprise database.
Right? This is something that
you can go catalog
and understand
how things are
what things exist
in the real world. Right?
This is in your real world
enterprise databases.
But this is what
you if you give
this to your data
consumers, right,
your data scientists,
your data analysts,
your BI developers,
They're gonna
scratch their head
because they don't
understand this,
and that's why you go back and
forth with your data data
producers to understand it.
So you wanna be
able to go create
your knowledge graph as adding
that layer of of knowledge,
the layer of semantics.
So imagine viewing
the data this way.
You see the main the the real
world business
concepts, orders,
customers, billing
address, order lines.
Right? A per
customer purchases
an order and so forth.
You wanna be able to go access
this data. Access
the data in terms of,
in terms of this
knowledge graph view.
But when you're creating that
first catalog, you're starting
to come up, for example,
with the business
glossary terms,
and that helps you bootstrap
what this is going
to look like.
Now the big differentiation
between having this kind of,
the the the the knowledge graph
view versus what
I what we call
the application
centric view is,
if I have this
particular question.
Right? What are the orders and
their net sales
in a given time
period per their status?
To answer that question,
I would have to write one SQL
query over that database,
and it would be
a very complicated
SQL query. Something
that's much
harder to to to maintain,
something that a small amount
of people can be
able to understand
because they need to know
understand the application
database.
But when you're
starting to talk
about what I what we
call the knowledge
and data centric view of it,
your queries I'll
be I understand
they're in graph and sparkle
that may be a new thing,
but just think about that.
The queries are
now in terms of
the knowledge view.
This it's a data
centric view of this.
And this everything now starts
to have a complete lineage.
So you if you're
asking what is
an order, I have
the connection
of what that concept order is
all the way back
to the original
application database.
That's why you
wanna be able to
start with
the metadata first.
So another aspect
that I really
want to push here
is that we all
think it's just
a technology problem.
It's not just
It's a that's a fallacy.
It's about culture too,
and I think this is the other
aspect that we want
you to take away.
First of all, we
talk about tools,
but what about the people?
Ask yourself,
what does success
look like? How do you know if
you're going to
build a knowledge
graph you're being
successful?
Who is responsible
for the data?
Assume that, you generate data
and and the data is being used
for to run some
machine learning
models to go make a decision,
and that and the decision that
was made was a failure.
It it sales went down.
Who's responsible for that?
On the contrary,
what if sales just increased
dramatically
because of the data
that was generated?
Who's responsible
gets promoted
for that? And, additionally,
who does the actual
knowledge work?
Who understands what these
concepts are and
understands how
they're supposed to what all
the different meanings and how
they're supposed
to be connected
to those physical databases?
I think this is this
is this is again,
this is not a problem solved
just by technology.
This is understanding
the people
who are involved,
understanding who is actually
going to be
consuming this data
and asking them what
success looks like.
Therefore, we need to be able
to understand what
are the business
needs, the business problems,
and tie everything that we're
doing with the data
to business value.
Otherwise, we're just having
we're we're we're
defining success
from a technical
point of view.
And I think this
is one of the key
problems. We have
been in the same
kind of rut in in enterprise
data management
because we define
success from a technical point
of view and not from a social
business point of view.
Bringing the data
into one place,
into one lake does not
solve my problem.
It solve the problem
is if the business
users are able to go answer
their questions.
That's how we need to
go define success.
Who is responsible
for the data?
We we treat software
with the respect
it deserves. It has a team.
It has a manager,
a product manager
that communicates
with the with
the with the users
of the software to
get the requirements
and translates
those requirements
to the engineers
and defines tests.
And we don't do
that for data.
We need to have this notion of
a data product manager,
and they're the ones who are
managing the this the datasets
that are coming out of that.
And who does this
knowledge work?
We all confuse we're
all confused,
and then we say that the data
scientists, right,
are the ones who's
supposed to do it,
and they complain
of the eighty
twenty rule. Right?
Eighty percent of the data
scientists spend their time
cleaning the data,
and then only
twenty percent of
the time they do
the analysis.
And that's true.
But now we treat this eighty
percent almost
with disrespect.
We say it's a data janitorial
work when it's the crucial
knowledge work,
that knowledge of what things
mean in our company.
So this needs to be kind of we
need to separate
it and make it
into its own diff own,
role and what we're calling
the knowledge scientist.
Now people work together,
and the question is,
how do they work together?
What are the processes that
people need to go to?
How do you avoid avoid boiling
the ocean? We don't wanna have
the old school
waterfall approach.
Yeah. How do people
work together?
Right? We need to have agile
agile methodologies,
what we're calling agile data
governance. And
one of the things
I always tell
people is, like,
why do we have
brakes in a car?
And the immediate
response usually
is is so we can go slow.
It's like, but no.
We have brakes in a car so we
can drive fast safely.
And that's the mentality that
we need to go think about when
we're thinking about data.
And how do people
work together?
The data product manager needs
to set up sprints.
We need to think about how to
document data.
We would never
dare release code
into a master
branch without any
comments. Why do we
do that for data?
We don't we don't
document it.
We don't document
how it's being
transformed,
the transformations,
the queries. We
don't do that.
We would never dare right now
to go release code
without anybody,
code reviewing it. Right?
We do pull requests.
People go review
our codes. Right?
We we even do peer
programming.
Why don't we do
that for data?
These are the these
are the social
aspects that we need
to go consider.
So to take away, frankly,
I think it's just time to
transform enterprise
data integration.
The way we have
been integrating
data has been the same.
So your data
catalog powered by
a knowledge graph.
Your first knowledge
graph should
be of your metadata,
of your tables and
columns. Why?
Because you need to know what
data you have.
And by know means
you need to have a knowledge.
That's what we're
talking about.
The knowledge graph of your
first knowledge
graph should be
should be of your
of your metadata.
And then your knowledge graph
should be powered by
the data catalog.
To build your
enterprise knowledge
graph, it needs to be done to
solve business pain points.
And I know people are gonna be
so tempted to run,
to jump and start
creating their
knowledge graph.
Please don't do that.
Why not? Because
you are basically
diving into the deep end,
and you will most
probably drown,
meaning you're
probably gonna fail.
And what's gonna
happen is that
when people start looking at
this knowledge graph,
they're gonna ask,
where does this
data come from?
How do I know I can trust it?
And the answer to that,
it's the metadata.
So that's why you should start
with the data
catalog as a strong
foundation of metadata.
Crawl and walk first in order
to succeed with your knowledge
graph to run.
And I know Brian
has some final
words here. No. I think yep.
Just just just as you said,
your data catalog is
a knowledge graph.
That knowledge
graph is actually
going to be a fundamental and
critical part of
your enterprise
knowledge graph of
knowledge graph.
The the knowledge in your
knowledge graph
isn't knowledge
if you can't kind
of state where
it comes from.
And that is exactly
what having
a model of your of of
your data assets,
the metadata about
your your your data,
your policies,
your organization,
and how it all
hangs together.
It is it is it is
the foundation
of your knowledge graph,
and it is fundamentally a part
of an integral part of having
a a real and
powerful knowledge
graph for your enterprise.
And and one final point is we
have to be very honest.
We're people who are here who
are attending this
the this this
conference, we're
all very excited,
but we even though
we see Gartner
and we see where
they're putting
knowledge graphs and
all that stuff,
this is frankly
still very early.
Right? People are
not companies
are not knocking on their door
on on and say, I want
a knowledge graph.
They do not have
a budget item,
the budget line item that says
go buy a knowledge graph.
They're not there yet.
So knowledge graph
is still new
in the industry.
There needs a lot of
education for it.
So we believe
that a way to get
knowledge graph
in is just focus
on a data catalog
powered by a knowledge
graph to sneak
in the knowledge
graph within an organization.
The value of a data catalog is
evident right now
to the business.
Right? There's magic quadrants
for data catalogs. Right?
There is a line item to go buy
a data catalog.
The market is
asking for a data
catalog now. So if you wanna
help the knowledge
graph industry grow,
start with the data catalog
powered by a knowledge graph.
And with that, thank
you very much.
I think, George,
you're you're on to
moderate questions?
Yep. Yeah. Yeah.
And, actually,
you've been quite
active in responding while,
you were giving the talk,
which is pretty unusual,
but also a little
bit unfair if
I compare to the other people
who gave talks because there's
two of you. So well done.
And, CEO also started
the conversation
with, Dean Alemanc
in the comments,
which I've been following with
with great interest.
And so I'll just relay,
the insulators
comment, basically.
So he's saying for
the benefit of,
the rest of the people
who may not,
have the chance to,
to to follow
the conversation.
So he's asking,
how do Juan's comments about
data governance
relate to the fact
that we'd like to reuse data
from outside organization?
We don't know if the external
data has undergone
the governance
that he talks about.
Does that mean that
we can't use it?
And he he hopes not.
And it's it's a long comment,
and it it includes a number of
questions, actually.
And then it he concludes by
asking how do we
reconcile the need
to manage data in the way Juan
is talking about
with the desire
to use external data. Yeah.
I mean, you know, I
can jump in on that.
That's what I I
think it's a it's
a great question.
And, you know, I
think, you know,
the answer is you can you can
represent that
external data as
as concepts and entities.
You can represent
what governance
has taken place if you know
about it externally and what
governance may
have taken place
on that internally. Right?
You know, the so, folks,
something we could
ask a lot is,
like, how do we deal
with data quality?
How do you kind of know that
only data only quality data is
within the within
the catalog?
And the answer is,
well, we we don't,
but we do in
the sense that data
quality isn't
an absolute isn't
an absolute thing. Right?
It's always kind
of use case and
need dependent.
So what you can do is you can
represent facts about data.
What what what
assessments have
been made? What ascertainments
have been made
about this data?
And then within
a particular context,
you can assess you
can assert policies,
which are what ascertainments
need to have been made about
this data in order
for it to be
useful for this
this use case.
And so the same piece of data
might be completely usable for
some kinds of research courses
purposes within
your organization.
It might be totally
unusable if
you're putting
together, you know,
your s a c SEC filings because
it hasn't gone through proper
proper vetting.
That's not two different
pieces of data.
It's it's not two different it
it is two
different ascertainments
of quality for
different purposes.
And and, you know,
third party data
is is absolutely,
you know, part of part
of your catalog.
You just need to understand
where did this data come from
and what what
governance has has
been been you know,
I would say,
though, like, if you know,
to to kind of, like,
back to the framing
of the question,
if you just bring in a catalog
of here's a bunch of open data
that we haven't really looked
at or or or
scrutinized or made
any ascertainments about,
you probably
shouldn't use that
for most for for most critical
use cases because you actually
don't you don't actually know
anything about
about the quality.
So you have to
really kinda have
a what factual quality as
ascertained to
the name and how
does that and how does that
relate to the policies of use
that I have? So so a couple of
things I wanna add.
One is you first need to go
catalog your own stuff to go
know what I have before you
wanna go bring other things.
Otherwise, you're just, like,
throwing stuff in the wall and
see what sticks.
Second, this should
be use case driven.
Right? Why why
are you going to
bring in this other data?
What is the problem
that you're
gonna try to solve with that?
So I think that's
how you wanna
be able to go bring
understand that.
And then once you realize that
I have this
particular use case,
this is the problem
I'm gonna go solve,
you're gonna bring in that
external data inside,
and and then you're gonna have
to add the governance
to it and
figure out, well,
can I actually
use this or not?
Right? I don't I mean,
we we're so kind of entrenched
now with these magic wands of
AI and stuff. It's like,
you put people in the room,
they won't even agree.
Why the heck do
we believe that
AI is gonna come
up with the right
answer when the humans
won't even agree?
We need to stop thinking about
that for for for I mean,
we need to kinda
really put our
our feet on the ground
on that aspect.
Now the I think the the way
the market is going
to get involved,
and this is much bigger than
knowledge graphs, is
a data marketplace.
A data marketplace is going to
be a data catalog
of your internal
and your external data.
And you're gonna see and so
you're you have data catalogs
for for folks to go use it
internally in their
in their enterprise,
and we're gonna start seeing
data catalogs of
open data that
are really starting
to add that
governance. And guess what?
So I think the winners are be
are the ones are
the data catalogs
that are gonna be
able to do both.
So take a look
and watch out for
data dot world for sure.
And I think I'm looking at one
of the chats there,
from Janine Hill
asking about,
the somebody was asking about
the ontology,
that that we that
we were talking about.
Frankly, the ontology we have
is is is out there. Right?
It's it's it's DCAD. It's DC.
It's it's all that stuff.
We internally have taken all
that stuff and added
some glue together.
Right? We need to go
connect that stuff.
And I I think part
of our plan is to,
we're cleaning it all up,
and we just wanna
go release it.
So we will be open
sourcing that
the Datadog World
enterprise catalog.
But note that it's all open
standards plus a bunch of glue
that we just added to that.
So we're gonna I think that's
something valuable
that the that
the industry needs.
Well, we can't We
don't have a paper
that discusses the glue,
but we probably should.
That'd be a good
that'd be a good
thing for us to do and prepare
for the engagement.
I am looking at that.
We'll get we'll have that
published soon. Yep. Okay.
So thanks to both of you.
So thanks once more,
and we're wrapping up, and,
see you in a bit. Thanks.